- [Narrator] The steering
wheel, the tire, the seat,
the rear-view mirror: utterly
standard parts of your car.
Except, in the mirror's case, it wasn't.
Cars were in use for over 30 years
before the rear-view mirror became common.
I guess people just swerved
and hoped for the best.
In fact, the first use
of the rear-view mirror
wasn't even for safety.
It was just a way for a
driver to go extra fast.
(lively music)
Back in the day, race
cars had a team of two:
the driver and a mechanic.
The driver drove, obviously,
and the mechanic fixed stuff.
But here's the critical thing.
The mechanic had one other duty.
They directed the driver
when the car was clear
to pass or change lanes.
Ray Harroun was a driver in
the 1911 Indianapolis 500,
and he was looking for an edge.
Ray figured that if he
ditched the mechanic
the car would be a lot lighter
and, therefore, faster.
So he borrowed an idea he
saw on a horse and buggy:
a mirror to change lanes.
He won the race.
But the mirror turned out to be so shaky
it didn't really catch on.
It took 10 years for someone else
to try experimenting with the mirror:
a guy named Elmer Berger.
Elmer was an engineer who
also like to go really fast,
but he wasn't a race car driver.
He just liked to speed.
So he created the mirror, and
he called it the cop spotter.
So, you see, it's not just for dads
checking on their kids
fighting in the back seat.
It's really about speeding.
So the next time that you're navigating
through a sea of cars
on some domestic errand
going really fast, and you see flashing
red and blue lights appear in that mirror,
you're using it as the founders intended.